[Music]
economists are calling this
the egyptian dream i'm anthony morris
and i'm in the ancient city of cairo
to understand the ambitious plans being
undertaken
by china and egypt to revolutionize
this region with the building of power
plants
highways and ports all across the land
and vital sea routes like the suez canal
that connect european waters with the
arabian ocean
egypt is powering its economy by
revolutionizing its manufacturing base
and a new administrative capital
we examine the ambitious plans being
undertaken by president sisi
and how china plans to fund them in this
silk road finale
beijing is developing a massive economic
plan
across countries and continents with the
one belt one road initiative
involving more than 65 countries china
is creating a new world order
through trade and commerce and the
middle east
and north africa are crucial markets for
chinese enterprises
to establish their economic hegemony
considered to be a cradle of ancient
civilization
egypt is our final destination for this
year's
silk road mired in history
cairo has been the capital for the last
1 000 years
welcoming traders and tourists alike
with this entrepreneurial flair
and hospitality and the chinese are
taking up the invitation
descending on the capital with their
traditional trade and commerce
it's aiming to use egypt as an economic
nerve center
a vital cog that sits in the middle of
europe africa
and the middle east egypt is the second
country on china's new maritime silk
route
and the one belt one road initiative
after pakistan
the plan is to increase china's maritime
traffic
to the mediterranean through the suez
canal
by developing several port cities for
manufacturing
and trade due to increased trade
president sisi is trying to make egypt a
critical trading partner with beijing
in the middle east and the remaining
countries on the one belt one road
a country of over 95 million egypt is
the most populous country in north
africa
and is being dubbed as china's gateway
to africa
fayez farahat an expert in economics and
geopolitics
is excited to see a new superpower
rising in the region
what role will egypt play in china's one
belt wind road
as it relates to china's access to
africa african markets yes because of
geographical
location of asia china can consider
egypt
as the gate for africa not only the gate
for africa but the gate for
the arab world the arab region europe
also
because egypt is near to the south of
europe
according to the map of one pelton road
i think egypt is located
a part of the maritime access of this
initiative egypt's political turbulence
has traditionally been a major handicap
for its economic development
the country has faced several political
upheavals from within
leading to mass instability and a
stagnant
economy the most prominent uprising
came at tahrir square in 2011 that led
to the ousting
of president hosni mubarak who had ruled
the country
for 43 years but the newly elected
president
mohammed morsi of the muslim brotherhood
didn't last long
the egyptian army mounted a coup and the
court sent morsi behind bars
for 25 years that brought egyptian
military chief
abdul fattah el-sisi to power who today
is the most powerful person in the
country and the president of egypt
since 2014 china is banking on him
for economic and political stability in
the region
the military intervention in the region
in
90s and also in 2003 in iraq and libya
the experience of the military
intervention of the western powers in
general in the middle east
they didn't lead to stability in the
middle east if
china is aiming to build
a multiballer system to the middle east
is important because that chef
have been made here this is why the
middle east is important
for china it will make the shaft from
the
unipolar system to the multiple system
president sisi met chinese premier xi
jinping in 2016
signing deals worth 17 billion u.s
dollars
for egypt in special economic zones and
joint productions with china
the relationship between the two is
steeped in history with chinese traders
for centuries
bringing goods through egypt and the
middle east before traveling onwards to
europe
stopovers like the khan ilkali bazaar
were critical for layovers
and conducting business it's one of the
world's
oldest covered markets having been
founded in 1382
due to the spice route trade between
europe and china
named after the great khans who
conquered egypt in the 14th century
the bazaar became a major center for
foreign trade
[Music]
so how old is the kanela kalili bazaar
oh medicine
[Music]
decided to help us get a closer feel of
the bizarre by dressing me up as one of
the great khan traders
of the 14th century
[Music]
all right thanks guys thanks guys
all right well as the saying goes
when in rome do as the romans do so
having a little light-hearted fun
getting dressed up as a con maybe what
they would have worn
when they walked through this great
bazaar hundreds of years ago
ornate gates and upper stories whose
external facades
lined with arabic scriptures where
merchants rooms were located
are preserved in time
today it is one frantic dizzying retail
extravaganza
where you can buy pretty much anything
from jeans and gold
to hookahs and magic oils
traditional workshops continue to
operate in the surrounding
area as night falls
the area is swarmed with tourists out to
buy trinkets
carpets and extravagant perfumes
while kadur has been walking through
these intricate bazaars
for years he understands that egypt has
the potential to be a global economic
player for china
in the region can you give a historical
perspective of the ancient silk route
and how it passed through egypt the
essence
is very ancient road for trade between
china and europe more than
three thousand years before crescent
now this is another new silk road
which we call built on for
within two years it will be reached
600 billion years dollar
the trade between china and africa
reaches billion
us dollars bilateral relations between
egypt and china have entered its 60th
year
and trade between the two has now
swelled into the billions
we visit the most important chinese man
in cairo today
to understand the extent of china's
footprint in egypt
han bing is the commercial and economic
attache
at the chinese embassy here in cairo he
is coordinating
this massive egyptian makeover with the
decision makers in beijing
as chinese investments are springing up
across the landscape
can you outline some of the major
chinese investments or companies that
are here in egypt when
we collect information from
the companies operating here
from china with chinese investment
we come to the finger near 7 billion
it's general authority
for the investment free zone of egypt
they have about 1300
companies registered in the in the cafe
but first we need to build
infrastructure like the the teta zone
ein sukna for the expansion area also
they are now constructing the
infrastructure
and expected to attract i think about 10
billion
us dollars we have many challenges here
first we need to know each other better
one biot one road initiative
we should see is the idea is the idea
presented to the world in this concept
we are focusing on the
five areas so first one is the policy
exchange the second one is
infrastructure connectivity
and third is for the trade and
investment
facilitation fourth is a financial
corporation and the last one is exchange
between the people so we are focusing on
these five
areas agreements with egypt in the
fields of manufacturing
and the development of ports and energy
sources have been
inked and are fast becoming a reality
but the thousand-year-old city of cairo
where all these agreements were signed
is struggling with one of the fastest
growing populations in the region
the old city of cairo has turned into a
congested mess
it takes hours to go from one point to
another making it highly unattractive
for foreign businesses to set a base
here in the capital
it's congested and chaotic with more
than 10 million inhabitants
cairo's infrastructure is not able to
meet the needs
of its people so they're moving it right
here
the new capital planned to be the size
of singapore
is due to have an airport larger than
london's heathrow
a building taller than paris's eiffel
tower
and ten thousand kilometers of roads
and avenues china fortune land
development
signed agreements with egyptian
authorities to develop parts
of the new capital it has signed a deal
to develop and manage
5700 hectares of egypt's new
administrative capital at a cost
of 20 billion us dollars and just a road
trip from old cairo
towards the new capital shows hundreds
of billboards
advertising the luxurious new lifestyle
that awaits the people
of egypt the city is planned to consist
of 21 residential districts from houses
ranging from
400 000 to 1 million us dollars
it's president cc's promise of a more
luxurious lifestyle
for those who can afford it it is
projected to have a population
of 5 million people in the next five
years and solve the chronic housing
problems of old cairo
ahmad sabur is one of the largest
developers in cairo
overseeing this massive initiative what
role is china playing
in egypt's housing market lots
to start with uh china state which is
one of the
it's the biggest largest company in the
world as far as i understand
or as far as i'm sure they are
it's a government-owned company they
just
signed the contract to develop the
central business district in the new
capital
it's a three billion dollar project
and it was signed on the day of the
launch i said that
it was a month and a half ago where we
attended this launch
three billion dollar project which is
all the office buildings all the
the business district of the capital so
this is not a housing project
it is planned that the new capital will
transfer the parliament
presidential palaces government
ministries and foreign embassies
all to this place it's estimated to be
completed between
2020 and 2022 and may
end up costing nearly 45 billion us
dollars
according to some estimates this massive
project however
hasn't come without its fair share of
problems
complications arose when chinese
contractors backed out
due to overpriced construction rates
critics further argued the reason for a
new capital
uprooting thousands of government
employees to be taken to a barren desert
area but the creation of jobs in the
construction sector
inside egypt finally led to a compromise
between the two countries
with the chinese companies that are
investing
in new cairo are they bringing in
chinese laborers
are they using local egyptians both
it needs to be a win-win chinese
companies great companies are coming
here to invest
in a very high potential country and
we are very happy that they make money
and make profits and make
more money and make more profits but we
have an
unemployment problem so it needs to be a
win-win
this win-win situation has attracted
powerful egyptian construction giants
like mountain view they're developing
projects
like the hyde park the largest landscape
park
in new cairo the company is headed by
ayman ismail
a private contractor who swiftly
invested in president sisi's dream of a
new capital
at a time when some chinese financiers
backed out
iman who later went on to head the
advisory board
on the new administrative capital as its
chairman
is excited about the new city situated
40 kilometers
outside of old cairo why is there a new
need for a new capital in egypt
it's not going to be a replacement to
the new capital it's going to be an
extension to the current capital
and that's very legitimate cairo won
last year and i say one
in a in a kind of uh you know sarcastic
way to a certain degree
the fastest growing city in the world
you know
in terms of population we've just added
half a million people
in cairo last year but there's more
to the egyptian chinese story than just
the new capital
with the launch of the new suez canal
being dubbed as the egyptian dream will
this canal
be able to withstand the massive
security and infrastructure challenges
the chinese proposal poses
chinese investments in egypt have poured
into the country
in the billions with more than 50
chinese private and publicly listed
companies
now operating in the country the one
belt one road initiative
has arrived in egypt but the jewel of
the egyptian crown
is the development of the new and
advanced suez canal
an economic zone spanning 460 square
kilometers
for more than 150 years the suez canal
has been the lifeblood
of the egyptian economy that has
undergone political
and military crisis opened in 1869 it
was completed
and largely owned by a british and
french company
egypt got back the ownership only in
1956
after former egyptian president jamal
abdul nasar
nationalized the suez canal and took
back control
it led to the suez canal crisis and the
region was thrown
into turmoil to win the suez canal back
militarily the united kingdom
france and israel attacked and invaded
egypt
the egyptian military struck back with
full force
a ceasefire was finally announced in
1957
after intense pressure from the united
states and the united nations
over the next 50 years the suez canal's
transformation
has been breathtaking as foreign
invaders were replaced with foreign
investors
in august 2014 president sisi announced
the expansion of the suez canal project
with much fanfare
to promote the economic lifeline of the
country
a new 72 kilometer canal was dug
parallel to the existing canal in two
years for two-way maritime
and cargo traffic by 2016 the two-way
suez canal
was ready to serve as a major maritime
trade route
entirely funded by the egyptian people
over 64 billion egyptian pounds were
raised through investment certificates
to fund its expansion today it's been
dubbed as the egyptian dream
promotional campaigns under president
sisi are selling their biggest
development project to the chinese to
develop special economic zones
around the canal
sewers canal economic zone is the
promising area
in november 2015 and on this land
a hopeful voice came out israel
today and after only two years the
promise has been fulfilled
the suez canal zone seeks to benefit
from its close proximity
to major maritime and economic markets
in the region
with abundant land and human resources
available
it aims to provide investors with a
market of
1.6 billion customers in the middle east
and north africa under preferential
trade agreements
egypt is developing industrial zones
along the canal
to boost the sc zone as a world-class
logistics
and trade center more than 1 million
jobs are expected to be created
over the next 15 years with shipbuilding
and repair made easy for international
traders
[Music]
and i'm at the suez canal one of the
most important geostrategic maritime
trading routes
and china is arriving in its customary
style
11 of chinese maritime trade passes
through the suez canal
to cater for the north african markets
beijing's trade with north africa aims
to increase the waterway capacity of the
suez canal
to reach 97 ships a day
that will potentially double egypt's
canal revenues from
6 billion u.s dollars to nearly 13
billion u.s
dollars annually and the role of this
man
is vital for the chinese who aim to
utilize the expanded suez canal
for two-way maritime traffic mohab
mamish
heads the suez canal authority and
reports directly
to president sisi himself and we've got
an exclusive
interview to find out more about egypt's
dream
project why was the new suez canal
an important project for president sisi
it was not for brazilian city it's also
for egypt
okay okay we made this subscribe not
for one person but for all the
egyptian people because we have some
troubles
in the system of jesus christ if you
have
any defective and ship you have to stop
all the source canal
because we are working in one leg only
but now we have two tracks
if something wrong in the track in one
track you can change the
navigation to the other track
and we are limited with the new ships
in the depths in the drafts of the ships
and
now we have many mega ships in the
fleets in the world we have to be ready
to trade with the new
standard of the ships we have to make
the
canada deeper wider
and faster
[Music]
singapore ports authority is also
working in the east port saeed
can you tell us a little bit more about
that as well i think for
they are very high experience we have a
very good
connection with them i start working
with them
and i convince our president
cece to come to visit san kapoor and i
visited san kapoor with him
because i have an very good
relation with them they are
very decent and they are very
straight and they are
very peaceful
[Music]
[Applause]
with the rise in china's trade to africa
to more than
80 billion us dollars annually the suez
canal is aiming to become
an international trading hub not only
for transit purposes
to serve as a manufacturing base for
chinese companies trading with
africa special economic zones or
secs are being developed under the one
belt one road plan
around the canal
what is the strategic importance of the
suez canal economic zone
we would like to show our experience how
to develop the economic zones
how will chinese companies benefit from
having the
made in egypt stamp on their products of
course they will have
the better access access to the
to the market around egypt or when
the egypt has this trade agreement with
these
countries and also i think here we
can have the lower cost
of the production and also investment in
the production
can help egypt to industrialization the
country
to get stronger in the economy that we
can
develop economic cooperation more
chinese companies are being promoted to
set up shop in egypt
due to cheaper costs of production and
its close proximity to a large consumer
market
in north africa you have the best
skilled labor
the position of egypt we can export to
let's say to
europe without any customs the same
thing
for the arab arab world to export the
same thing
for the commercial and we can export to
africa without customs
one of the most important port cities
inside the suez canal economic zone
is ayinsokna a port that connects the
red
sea and the mediterranean as part of the
one belt one road initiative
one of the leading chinese companies is
ensuring that more
investments flow here the tida group
one of the oldest industrial developers
in china have created this seven square
kilometer industrial zone
which now has 68 chinese companies
due to chida's economic zone chinese
fiberglass manufacturing giants
have flown in to ain soknap port in
style
jushi egypt arrived here two years ago
and today
has a total investment of 223
million us dollars making it the biggest
private chinese investment
in egypt jushi has had an immediate
impact on the local economy
it has hired more than 1 900 egyptian
workers
to boost the local employment in the
region and is only a limited number
of 50 chinese staff members by setting
up a manufacturing base in the suez
canal economic zone
jushi is now exporting 95 percent of its
goods from
ayan sokna to europe and north africa as
a result
freight costs for jushi have greatly
reduced in comparison to its earlier
shipments that arrived via sea routes
from their headquarters
in the chinese city of jiesyang jushi's
move to egypt has made it more
competitive and efficient what role does
tita play
in juxi's operations here this error
belong to tida investment
so when we come here the cheetah support
us to make make this factory and
they support us to finish our lessons
and support us our guests however all
the things
after this week running smooth
the labor from egypt is cheaper than
china
it's first it's the most important thing
but not the first
the first for the miner you know
egyptians have
many many different means to manufacture
the fiberglass
in order to attract more foreign
investment as a manufacturing hub
egypt is positioning itself as the
export gateway
to north africa and europe does having a
made in egypt stamp
uh on juicy products is that beneficial
for the company
yes for the fiberglass export from china
to
to europe it's a has a very high tax
but from here we send our production to
the europe
no tax big benefit for us to relocate
here to egypt
yes so it's the most important thing we
come here
you know the tax uh nearly the 36
percent juchi has also been able to cut
down taxes
by taking advantage of the tax breaks
being provided by the egyptian
government for foreign investors
with increased profits juxie is already
setting up
a new manufacturing plan in egypt future
not a very long distance
next year we already purchased another
land for new workshop next year we will
finish all the workshops
such as the package manufacturer
workshop
silica burner limestone milling workshop
and the
natural gas station yes tita is very
important for us
i can say no tida no no juicer
with a rise in chinese firms egyptian
firms aren't holding back
and are signing joint manufacturing
agreements to bring
chinese products to egypt after the
break we delve into egypt's automobile
sector and meet the man
who is making chinese cars famous in the
country
china's one belt one road initiative is
sweeping across the middle east and
north africa
and egypt is making its presence felt
hundreds of contracts worth billions of
dollars have been signed with the
chinese
in energy manufacturing and special
economic zones it's transforming the way
egyptians work think and live and if
there is one thing that the egyptians
love
it's their love for imported cars
traditionally an importer of german and
american cars
it is now locally manufacturing joint
productions
of chinese cars they're cheap and easy
to make in less than 10 years
the egyptian automotive business has
grown from just three plants to now
manufacturing nearly
100 000 units of passenger cars per
year and plants like this in cairo are
churning out
100 cars a day to satisfy the needs of
the egyptian people
gabor autos is responsible for 96
of chinese cars being sold in cairo and
its founder ralph gabor has been
nicknamed the chinese ambassador
in egypt in 2016 alone he sold more than
12 000 chinese brands gili and cherry
20 years the chinese have proven to be
able to achieve
in much shorter period of time and i
believe that
they are not far away in terms of
quality today
especially when you talk about companies
which both i'm here
stating the example of gd gb bought
volvo a few years back and
today we see clearly the impact of the
acquisition
their product quality and styling has
improved tremendously
if i would quantify the quality gap it's
it would be no more than 10
which i see in the next very few years
will be closed can captioning not
available
25 years ago both korea and china chose
testing markets so they chose some
markets where
they are they were testing their
products korea didn't start
exporting to the world they started
exporting to some middle eastern
countries and african countries and when
they
tested the products performance in
offshore markets they started then
uh developing and and they developed
their management skills to cope with
the requirements of export markets then
they started expanding
to uh other markets this is exactly what
china has done rising egypt china
manufacturing
has created a positive mood amongst most
egyptians as lots of hard cash is
flowing
into the country as part of the one belt
one road deals egypt will be receiving
millions of dollars
in loans to finance massive development
projects
it's increased egypt's foreign reserves
in a country that was starved of hard
cash
after the political turmoil that hit the
country in twenty eleven
ahmed the head of the egypt china
business council
the body responsible to facilitate
chinese investments in the country
is satisfied with the progress it was
quite clear in the last 20 years that
the
trade with china is being more and more
ever every year
and the relation between the gulf
countries and the egypt it have been
also
growing in the last 20 years a lot of
china now having a lot of technology and
a lot of know-how
and now they're not only exporting now
goods they're exporting every technology
and factories so i believe with this
road it will be better for the chinese
to find
better markets and at the same time for
egyptian and for the gulf region
to find a better partner and more easy
partner
chinese loans and investments in
development projects
are being welcomed despite clarity on
what the interest rates would be
to the public despite the risk that
egypt poses for potential investments
omar el-shaneti an investment expert
believes that the chinese know where and
how much
to invest definitely the chinese
investments are
very critical and strategic and to a
very big extent they are different than
the rest of the investments
that we are getting for very specific
reasons number one
um i would say that china in general is
uh
is more prone to risk chinese
institutions
have been used to invest across africa
and we as a firm have worked a lot in
different countries in africa
and whenever you go you see chinese
companies and contractors and
infrastructure companies
so china as a nation and chinese
companies
are used to high risks so they view the
country here as
generally quite a good risk when you
compare it to other places they are used
to this is number one
number two uh chinese do not come to
just lend
money to the government or to banks but
they really come
with projects as they say in economics
the higher the risk the higher the
return
and han bing the chinese economic and
commercial attache believes that
egypt's risks are being viewed as
china's opportunities by beijing
but we are expecting situations
stabilizing and the economy is
recovering when
we saw that the last quarter
the egyptian economies has the
4.9 growth
so this gives the good competence for
the overall economic situation from the
egyptian
business people to chinese business
people
they have a different approach and we we
need to find the
the way that connect be accepted by by
both sides
so the culture the difference is
is that quite big the both sides should
accommodate
or not besides all these challenges we
believe
that our cooperation will have very
bright future
and i think now the
is the time for chinese companies
to come to egypt for the investment
after the break we visit the chinese
cultural center
to see how cultural barriers are being
broken down
and meet with an egyptian chinese couple
who are introducing
dragon boating to the nile
china's one belt one road has arrived in
egypt
with billions of dollars of investments
and projects
the chinese dragon has landed in this
african nation
from joint productions in manufacturing
to facilitating ports
to propelling chinese products to the
european markets
they have all been inked it doesn't end
there
there's a cultural exchange also going
on between the two countries
the two thousand year old chinese sport
of dragon boat racing
has found a new waterway on egypt's nile
river
a dragon boat academy has been
inaugurated
at the royal muhammad ali club in giza
and has garnered the interests of
chinese and egyptian nationals in the
area
mary lai is solely responsible for this
interesting development
but it all began with a sweet egyptian
chinese
love story i came here to study arabic
so first of all i love culture and i
love language and this
language become a key to for me open
many doors
so one of the key i find my husband nice
okay
and you've been married for how many
years now no it's just only
uh five years five years yes okay and i
think this is one of the beautiful
things
um that we're seeing on you know the one
belt one road or
these kind of cross-cultural or uh
intercultural marriages in china you
find it too you find people from egypt
who have
married chinese women or living there
speak perfect mandarin
here you are someone from hong kong have
married an egyptian
and you speak fluent arabic yeah you
later will see
my husband nihab and he's the coach he's
the first
egyptian he go to hong kong and china to
get training
as a dragon boat coach what's the idea
is
uh because egyptians have a civilization
and chinese also civilization and we
bring this civilization together
the dragon ball and the river now mary's
husband ihop has been working hard
on spreading dragon boating after he
mastered the sport
in hong kong and guangzhou that han here
your hand to hand the street okay
you're here near the boat okay
and then you sit this leg is up
this leg it's back down like that okay
and you your hand two straight so you
push
he is currently training several groups
of players to prepare for the next
festival
in cairo where dragon boat teams from
spain cyprus
and others will take part the trainees
mostly dragon boating for the first time
are excited during the ride
as they sit in two rows and learn how to
harmoniously row their sticks together
what are the future plans for the dragon
boating federation
i think we have a different stages we
are in the beginning stage so we treat
it as a community sport
it's a culture it's a game a water game
you know
and then slowly we probably will be
uh to establish federation but still
too early because we just want as a
community
team building a culture game i think
the culture we need to learn how to
appreciate one another so
one by one role to give this uh beside
the economy but also in the culture side
to let the egyptian understand our
chinese culture what is the story about
the dragon ball
because we last time in may we do a
dragon ball festival
and then we make a a story to tell them
what is the story about dragon ball and
it was really
amazing because the story of dragon ball
is a very nationalism
you know so and they really appreciate
and they understand
and for in the future we want the
egyptian
to have the team the dragon ball team to
go to china
so they have more exchange more
understand one another
with this foundation i believe in the
future no matter the economy and all the
infrastructure
will be helping because for the mutual
understanding of one another
civilization
to understand the sport better ehob
invited me to the biggest challenge of
them all
my team was being pitted against the
mighty muhammad ali club
after some light training off we went to
the nile's greatest dragon boating
competition
so right now we just came out from where
we uh got on the boats
we've had a little bit of practice yeah
uh what's gonna happen next are we gonna
race these guys
yes yes this is the muhammad ali club
teams it's a very strong team
and we prepared this team to be to go
play outside egypt
we hope so in the future and we
practice this team to make him stronger
and already he's famous and deliver now
too
so just to let you know we're going up
against an established team
we've we've dubbed ourselves the nile
dragons yes
and we're gonna take on the team let's
see how we do yes yes that's we go
let's go all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
on this beautiful day we've enjoyed a
friendly competition
on these dragon boats here on the famous
nile river
and though the opposing team clearly won
our coach here said in the end it was
really a situation of win-win
and i think that so typically uh
represents the spirit
of the one belt one road initiative
egypt's dragon boat academy was
inaugurated by the chinese embassy here
in cairo
its chinese cultural center in the heart
of cairo plays a vital role
in merging cultural and linguistic
barriers between the two nations
this is the first chinese cultural
center in the middle east
and it has been running for the past 15
years
and i've been invited to learn about one
of china's most ancient martial arts
forms
right here
[Music]
tai chi short for tai chi chuan is an
internal chinese martial art practice
for both its defense training
and its health benefits
mark is a chinese tai chi teacher who
came to cairo two years ago and has seen
egyptians taking a keen
interest in this art form how long have
you been practicing tai chi
when i was a young boy i followed my
grandpa
practically taiji maybe 10 years old
the people here in egypt who take your
classes are they enjoying the practice
yes i sing them everyone like this
why do you practice tai chi oh yes
because
i think the taiji is it's chinese
traditional
arts martial arts i think it's a culture
and
it's a chinese style
uh kung fu and i think it's a keep your
health a good for your healthy and every
day you can practice i think is a
a good spot first when we rest
open
mark invited me to a class of tai chi
along with his devoted egyptian
followers
it is believed that focusing the mind
solely on the movements of the form
helps to bring about a state of mental
calm and clarity
besides general health benefits stress
management attributed to traditional
chinese medicine
is taught as well
[Music]
it's amazing to see this ancient martial
art form
being introduced on the one belt one
road and being practiced
by modern egyptians here in cairo
along with tai chi daily mandarin
classes
have garnered immense interest from the
people of cairo
reducing cultural barriers between these
two great civilizations
[Music]
the man responsible for this is the
cultural attache of the chinese embassy
in cairo
mr yang yang he believes that the first
step to bring chinese companies here
is to develop greater cultural
understanding first
year
[Music]
this greater cultural understanding has
allowed a greater acceptance of chinese
investments
across the one belt one road
my journey started in the chinese city
of ningxia
where i saw how china is on a charm
offensive to promote its silk road
vision to
countries in the middle east
[Music]
in pakistan where an economic corridor
is reducing terrorist violence with a
renewed focus
on job development in iran
a crippled economy is now re-emerging on
the world stage with the arrival of the
iron silk road
and here in egypt i've seen how
international trade and cooperation
can have a positive impact and bring
political
and social stability as ties between
countries along the one belt one road
strengthen
many people in this ancient land believe
that integrated economies
can help create a better connected and
stable world
[Music]
you